mắt tình người, cảnh sát cơ động giúp người quyết tật gồm lối trạng người.
Châu may tạm thăng tư trên đường làm những vụ qua giá hí ẳng quảng ai,
tổ công tác cảnh sát cơ động phát hiện một người đàn ông quyết tật chân,
đang lấy hoài gồm lối phơi vèn đường khi chởi sắp mười lớn.
Ngay lập tức, các chiến sĩ dừng xe, sánh tay cùng bà con hình chương thu ngong nông sản trạng người.
Thế ngảnh các chiến sĩ hỗ trợ người đàn ông yêu thế giới thời thường, khi người dân vô cùng xúc đồng.
Nhìn các chú dừng lại giúp bà con thề quy lắm,
cảm ơn các chiến sĩ rất nhiều, một người dân chia sẻ.
Cảm giác gần gũi, âm áp làng toả khắp sống nhỏ giữa mùa gặp.
Câu chuyển sản dị tại quảng ai đã có phần lắng toả mạnh mẽ hình Ấn đẹp của người chiến sĩ công hàn gần dân,
sát dân và hết lòng viên dân dân phục bụng.